[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel David Madeleine
blaimerait bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
commission rouleau c'est achève
la bin tout à l'heure courage parce que
bon Louis Blouin avait commencé
Madeleine plusieurs jours vous êtes chef
de bureau il avait ils ont vaillant
c'est pas évident tous les jours c'est
pas comme la commission Gomez ou
d'autres commissions où il y a un côté
quand même on va le dire spectaculaire
et un côté oh là c'est bon mais bref
c'est quand même important la question
qu'on pose que la Commission se pose
est-ce qu'il était nécessaire pas
d'avoir recours à une loi d'exception
qui bafoue certains droits fondamentaux
alors c'est ça
on va écouter madame Freeland
aujourd'hui qui a fait la manchette qui
dit en deux mots on me disait qu'on
avait l'air d'une république de bananes
on me disait que en plus on voulait
avoir des exceptions au libre-échange on
dit si vous bloquez pas plus je demande
et nous pas des faveurs à dire il y
avait urgence bref on écoute
very very Flash
urgence donc dit-elle Chantal ce qu'on
avance
ce qu'on avance un peu depuis le début
de la semaine c'est qu'on est en train
d'étendre les critères de ce qui
constitue une menace à la sécurité
nationale et ça a commencé lundi avec le
patron
pas la définition qui est écrit dans la
loi qui est la même que celle du acrs
mais néanmoins je les conseillé au
Premier ministre parce que je pensais
que c'était la chose à faire
ça s'explique le problème c'est que
en élargissant la définition de la loi
on s'embarque sur une pente drôlement
savonneuse néanmoins est-ce qu'un blocus
ferroviaire autochtone est une menace à
la sécurité nationale parce que ça a des
impacts sur l'économie est-ce que un
blocus fondé sur une bataille
environnementale contre un Oléo duc ou
autre est une menace à la sécurité
nationale et ce qu'il faut souvenir
c'est en au-delà du spectacle de ce que
Monsieur Trudeau va dire demain c'est
que ce que la Commission va conclure sur
la foi des arguments qu'elle entend ça
va servir de modèle pour les
gouvernements qui vont venir après qui
seront pas nécessairement libéraux ou
qui penseront pas nécessairement de la
même façon sur ces questions là alors
c'est intéressant cette tentative
d'élargissement mais ça comporte des
risques pour l'avenir
détermination si Justin Trudeau en
respecté ou non le critère actuel parce
que comme le disait Chantal même le chef
du service canadien renseignement disait
bon la définition ne s'applique pas au
sars mais elle peut s'appliquer au
gouvernement alors que c'est la même
définition de sécurité nationale c'est
quand même assez surprenant qu'un même
homme est deux interprétations pour une
seule même une seule définition
il a dit mais je vous conseille à la
question de l'utiliser en début de
semaine on en a parlé Michel David
monsieur Trudeau oui on le souligné
demain et conclut tout ça
c'est quand même important ce qui est en
jeu parce que si jamais le juge rouleau
mais beaucoup beaucoup de bémol
c'est politiquement c'est embêtant oui
jusqu'à un certain point mais écoutez la
question est pas de savoir s'il fallait
mettre fin à l'occupation de la capitale
tout le monde là-dessus tout le monde
est d'accord c'est de savoir si la façon
dont on a procédé
correspondait aux exigences de la Loi
j'entendais madame frelan là tout le
monde interprète la sécurité nationale à
sa façon le droit les réputation du
Canada là c'est pas nulle part dans la
loi ça et je pense qu'on aurait beaucoup
plus avancé si le fameux avis juridique
du ministère de la justice dont on parle
et qui semble-t-il consacrerait une
interprétation plus large que ce qui est
prévu dans la loi du SCRS était rendu
public on avancerait un peu mais là sous
prétexte que c'est couvert par le
privilège à vos coques clients alors on
le garde de confidentiel mais le client
qui est le gouvernement pourraient très
bien dire non écoutez moi j'ai pas
d'objection à ce que on le rende public
et c'est pas ce que l'on fait alors tant
qu'on sera pas ce qu'il y a là-dedans le
doute ne peut que persister
Chantal jusqu'ici on verra demain
jusqu'ici néanmoins est-ce que le
gouverne la thèse du gouvernement tient
la route croyez vous
il y a deux niveaux là dessus le premier
niveau c'est le niveau juridique et le
jeu goulot est pas mal plus qualifié que
moi pour déterminer ce genre de question
là l'autre niveau c'est l'opinion
publique et selon moi au niveau de
l'opinion publique et un sondage à
Bacchus la fin octobre qui montre que
l'appui en particulier au Québec mais à
l'échelle du Canada est majoritairement
du côté du gouvernement là-dedans donc
personne n'a rien entendu qui
faisait changer d'idée parce que la
majorité des Canadiens ont toujours
appuyé ce recours là ça a pas bougé ça
c'est à la fin octobre je dirais vu de
l'extérieur qui est rien arrivé depuis
la fin octobre qui aurait fait pencher
la balance d'opinion publique de l'autre
côté et là-dessus c'est une des grandes
différences pas seulement de côté
spectacle avec le la Commission gommery
on sait déjà le gouvernement Justin
Trudeau tombera pas sur cette question
là le MTD a déjà annoncé que ce serait
pas une raison pour se désister de son
pacte avec les libéraux et jusqu'à
présent l'opinion publique est encore là
où le gouvernement voudrait qu'elle soit
c'est à dire en faveur de
suspectivement de la décision de
me permettre j'ai l'impression que moi
que la population jusqu'à un certain
point s'en fout elle est passée à autre
chose il fallait dégager ça prenez les
moyens qu'il faut puis on passe à
d'autres choses alors je vois même pas
que ça soit vraiment un enjeu très très
important pour au plan politique mais ce
qui ne veut pas dire puis je commençais
comme ça en disant les journalistes ils
sont tapés tout ça ce qui ne veut pas
dire que c'est des principes
fondamentaux Madeleine en démocratie
qu'on est en train d'étudier malgré tout
là c'est ça reste important c'est pour
ça qu'il faut en parler oui parce que
une prochaine fois ça pourrait être pour
quelle raison justement qu'on
invoquerait cette loi-là et on brimerait
qu'elle liberté fondamentale puis
c'était un gros test pour le
gouvernement cette semaine il y avait
plusieurs ministres qui témoignaient
pendant plusieurs heures et un des
risques c'était de se contredire et
Patrice vous disiez bon c'est des
longues heures des longues semaines puis
cette semaine il y avait aussi la Coupe
du Monde puis je présume qu'il y avait
certains journalistes qui avaient à la
fois le match de soccer sur un écran
puis la commission sur l'ordre
c'est comme lorsqu'on arrive à un fin à
une fin de match nulle et on voit des
tirs de barrage c'est comme si il y a
aucun des joueurs qui devait rater le
filet cette semaine sans quoi c'était
comme toute la partie qui était en jeu
donc aucun des ministres ne devaient
rater son coup parce que ça pouvait être
tout l'argumentaire du gouvernement qui
s'écroule si on commence à se contredire
du côté du gouvernement et c'est pas
arrivé ça jusqu'à maintenant il reste le
test de Justin Trudeau demain demain
juste un Trudeau et demain Justin
Trudeau il a déjà dit je vais je vais
vous entendre là-dessus après je vais
parler un peu plus en français que mes
collègues pour ce qui a parti le bal je
le rappelle pour qu'on comprenne mieux
l'extrait de Monsieur Trudeau c'est que
Monsieur Vignaud le grand patron du SCRS
est un francophone que l'on voit là et a
décidé il a le droit de décider ça mais
il a quand même décidé de faire 100 % de
son témoignage en anglais répondent aux
questions en anglais ce qui a pour ce
qui nous a forcé nous et plusieurs
autres à poser des questions sur la
façon de faire et le français dans cette
commission qui est à peu près absent de
depuis le début on va écouter monsieur
Trudeau puis je vous donne la parole
je trouve que c'est dommage qu'il n'y
ait pas eu assez de français pendant la
commission évidemment je vais essayer
d'utiliser autant que possible pour que
tout le monde puisse me comprendre dans
les deux langues officielles mais on
sait aussi aussi qu'il y a la traduction
en français
des fois c'est difficile de répondre en
français aussi mais je sais qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui ont fait des efforts
puis moi aussi je veux faire des efforts
monsieur Leblanc qui a parlé un peu il
fait référence à monsieur Leblanc qui a
parlé un peu français Chantal qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ça parce que la
traduction il y a la il y a des
interprètes la tradition simultanée est
disponible pour tout le monde aussi
Chantal
c'est vrai que la majorité des ministres
est Dominique Leblanc étant l'exception
on peut comme première langue le
français et Madeleine lui expliquer
c'était le genre de semaine où l'erreur
était pas permis au ministre alors ils
se sont limités au maximum mais quelque
part et c'est pas la faute du juge
rouleau en passant qui fonctionne
totalement en français
c'est sa langue ils ont fondé une
association qui s'appelle l'Association
des juristes de langue française de
l'Ontario pour mémoire mais je pense que
quelque part ça fait quand même
l'affaire du gouvernement pas et je
crois pas qu'il y a une directive mais
quand on regarde l'état de l'opinion le
plus gros de l'ouvrage de convaincre que
le gouvernement avait raison se faisait
en anglais à l'extérieur du Québec et
c'est là que les arguments avaient le
plus besoin d'être étayés donc j'en
conclus que oui c'est particulier mais
d'autres parts je pense que Monsieur
Trudeau est mieux entendre monsieur
Vignon CRS en anglais dans tous les
bulletins de Noël lundi soir c'était
lundi que de l'entendre en traduction
parce qu'il y avait des grands bouts
comme francophone même un des avocats
lui a demandé à Monsieur vous êtes sûr
vous n'êtes pas vous voulez pas aller en
français parce que vous essayez
d'expliquer quelque chose de complexe sa
première langue c'est le français
de Montréal puis bon il part très bien
anglais par ailleurs Michel David
je comprends que pour des raisons
politiques on voulait s'adresser
davantage à une auditoire anglophone
mais au-delà de ça là moi je pense que
c'est ça à quoi on assiste c'est
extrêmement ça reflète parfaitement ce
qui se passe
la fin de l'appareil fédéral et de la
haute fonction publique l'anglais c'est
la langue
dans laquelle on peut être compris c'est
tenu pour acquis alors tout le monde se
met à l'anglais francophone ou
anglophones je pense que c'est la
mentalité qui pour beaucoup une
mentalité de
le dire qui est qui régit à peu près
tout là-bas alors j'ai pas été surpris
le moindrement déçu oui de la part de la
particulier des ministres qui sont
capables même s'ils sont pas
francophones qui sont capables de faire
un effort mais pas surpris du tout
Madeleine
pas surprise non plus mais pas surprise
de la part par exemple des hauts
fonctionnaires pas surprise même de
David Vignon qui est parlé en anglais
parce qu'il est à la tête du Service
canadien de renseignement de sécurité
peut-être que ça se passe souvent en
anglais tout le monde nous le dit dans
une réunion où il y a 10 francophones un
anglophone on va finir par parler tous
anglais on me le répète à chaque fois
donc ça fonctionne comme ça oui mais il
y a aussi un exercice politique qui
s'opère en ce moment et Chantal a raison
de dire bon on veut faire valoir des
points de vue technique mais d'un autre
point de vue il y a des francophones qui
écoutent il y a des francophones qui
réalisent que pas un mot qui se dit en
français de la part de plusieurs
ministres Christophe Willem bon je l'ai
suivi jusqu'à à peu près 14 heures elle
n'avait pas prononcé un seul mot en
français David lametti pas un seul mot
et c'est quand même un ministre de
Montréal donc ça j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont perdu des points d'un point
de vue linguistique là-dessus alors que
le gouvernement est dans une position un
peu de fragilité un peu vulnérable
là-dessus après avoir nommé une
lieutenant de gouverneur
dans la seule province bilingue au pays
avoir nommé une gouverneur général qui
ne parle pas français sur la scène
nationale donc tout ça il me semble que
le gouvernement aurait dû le savoir et
Justin Trudeau le dire je vais faire
l'effort je suis un peu déçu mais
peut-être qu'il y aurait dû envoyer le
mémoire ces ministres aussi oui
mais que comme il est anglophones parce
que c'est technique vous l'avez dit
Chantal oui il y a un objectif politique
de parler davantage dans ce cas-ci au
Canada anglais mais que quand
francophone ne dise pas un mot de
français ça pue surprendre quand même
Chantal
et malheureusement le mémo dont
Madeleine
mais je pense que le seul mémo qui a été
envoyé au ministre c'est s'il vous plaît
ne vous mettez pas le pied dans la
bouche
et probablement choisissez la langue
dans laquelle vous êtes le plus
confortable parce que oui
aurait pu parler français mais je pense
que pour avoir parlé à certains d'entre
eux avant il y en a qui étaient
terrorisé
non mais les ministres encore une fois
moi c'est pas ça qui éveillé le plus de
points d'interrogation dans mon esprit
c'est pas les ministres c'était
davantage des francophones il y a eu un
sous-minet il y a eu un conseiller de la
ville de tawa francophone francophone
francophone je me suis dit aussi ceux-là
où il y a une disparition complète du
français c'est là que on peut on peut se
demander est-ce que c'est devenu comme
ça est-ce que c'est la norme est-ce que
le conseiller municipal si je me
fonctionne pas c'est faire abrouer par
un avocat parce que il demandait des
précisions en français parce que c'est
un point technique qui voulait être sûr
de bien comprendre et on l'a presque
ridiculisé il reste une minute est-ce
que je peux Michel David vous demander
où on en est dans les limbes de la
reconnaissance des partis à Québec
est-ce qu'il y a de la fumée blanche
est-ce que un accord il y a pas d'accord
mon impression c'est qu'on est tout près
d'un accord qui a pas été officialisé
mais que je pense que au PQ ce qui
disons les offres finales ou sont jugés
à satisfaisant alors je m'attends à ce
qu'il y a un accord très rapidement
maintenant faut pas oublier que cet
accord-là ne va être pratiquement en
vigueur que quand le PQ va accepter
d'entrer en chambre à l'Assemblée
nationale et je pense pas que le PQ va
va participer à la session la courte
session qui va sa journée le 10 décembre
quand la question va se reposer
au début de 2023 je vous rappelle c'est
mercredi et Chantal Michel vous serez
avec nous pour cette émission spéciale
le discours inaugural à Québec mercredi
monsieur Legault merci à vous trois
bonne soirée au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI